hello and welcome back to
learning with jagman x
today i'll take you through how to add
animation into your 3d scenes using
rotoscoping i've always been inspired by
traditional frame by frame animation and
i find there's something really soothing
about how the imperfections peek through
as it flickers throughout each of its
frames as i started to endeavor into
creating cinematics in unreal engine i
started to realize that i could get a
similar look using rotoscope animation
and the more that i've used it the more
i actually adore the way that it looks
what is rotoscope animation rotoscope
animation describes the process of
creating animated sequences by tracing
over live action footage frame by frame
and why use rotoscope animation this
offers an animation style that is
stylized and unique while also being
relatively simple to achieve by anyone
who has the patience to see it through
even if you truly believe that you lack
any artistic skill then you too could
achieve animation through this approach
and i'm going to share with you how i
use rotoscope animation in my unreal
engine products step by step i also want
to clarify that even though i'm using
unreal engine for this tutorial the
steps can still be applicable for other
game engines or 3d projects step one is
to plan your animation when planning
where rotoscope animation would be best
to use within your project do keep in
mind that it is quite a lengthy process
so the best rotoscope animations are
ones that are short and easily loopable
the first frame of the animation should
match up with the last frame so that it
can smoothly transition throughout the
whole movement when put on a loop
because of this i usually come up with
really basic actions that i can put on a
loop throughout my 3d scene so this
might be somebody sipping a cup of
coffee somebody walking on the spot a
person playing a musical instrument a
bird flapping its wings
you get the point step two figure out
your camera angle so the rotoscope
animations will be imported into your 3d
environment as a 2d sprite animation
therefore it will only be viewable from
the front or the back it's not a 3d
object because of this it's vital that
you create your animation to fit the
correct angle within your scene this is
especially if you have fixed cameras
throughout your project so if you're
making a cinematic
music video film whatever it is or a
fixed camera video game to do this you
can simply line up your camera to the
scenes where you want the animation to
play and take a photo of this angle so
that you can use this as reference when
creating it
to take a high resolution screenshot in
unreal engine you can press f9 or use
the high resolution screenshot tool
within the viewport options but if
you're unsure what angle you will be
using for your animations then do not
worry just make sure to film your
animations from front on and you can
make sure that the 2d sprite will always
look at your camera or your player step
3 film your animations now it's time to
get some reference for your rotoscope
animation by filming the actions that
you need if you took screenshots of your
3d scene as a reference then try to
match up the scene as best as possible
so that when you film your action it
will be at the correct angle for your
scene film each action separately and
try to make sure they're not too long
you will thank yourself in the next step
trust me and don't forget to keep in
mind that the action needs to loop from
beginning to end so try to make sure the
end of the action will line up with the
beginning the best thing about this is
that you only need your footage to use
as a reference to create your animation
so you don't need to go out and buy a
fancy camera you can simply use your
phone just ensure that your camera is
stationary to make sure that each frame
of your action lines up perfectly with
the other you can invest in a phone
tripod for this which i find very useful
step four draw over your videos in
photoshop now it's time to art
import your reference video into the
animation timeline of photoshop when
this is imported you can use it as
reference to draw over in a transparent
new layer skim over the video every few
frames and keep creating a new layer per
chosen frame to draw onto the more new
layers you create and the closer the
frames are to one another the smoother
your animation will be and as you create
more and more layers you'll slowly start
to see your animation come to life don't
forget that we must have the end frame
loop nicely with the first frame and
make sure that they're all the same
canvas size this can be extremely time
consuming but it all depends on how much
time you'd like to spend on your
animation for my projects i simply draw
a thick white line over the outline and
the details of my reference i like to
use white so that i can easily
manipulate the color once i import it
into a game engine through this method
of drawing every few frames it also
allows me more creative freedom to add
things into the animation that weren't
necessarily there in the reference
footage such as steam coming from a hot
coffee mug glittering effects particles
bugs coming from a stinky dog if you
want to do that overall i find this step
very therapeutic i know not everyone
will but i do and it's extremely
rewarding to see your animation come to
life step 5 export as a sprite sheet
once you're happy with your animation
you'll then need to export this as a
sprite sheet to use in unreal engine
this feature actually isn't in built
into photoshop so you'll have to add a
photoshop script yourself so you can do
this i put a link in the description
where you can find a photoshop script
and it's called layers to sprite sheet
once you've downloaded this you can then
put it into your program files adobe
photoshop presets scripts folder and
then close and reopen your photoshop to
make sure that the script is accessible
for you it's good practice to make a
duplicate of your photoshop file here
just in case you need to go back in the
future and make further changes to the
original file before you turn it into a
spreadsheet within your duplicate
photoshop file delete the timeline so
that all of your layers will be active
on top of one another it should look
like one big squiggly mess then delete
the video and background layer leaving
only the layers that you want to be
included into the sprite sheet select
all of the layers and go into file
scripts and choose layers to spreadsheet
insert how many sprites per row you'll
need and this will depend on how many
image layers the animation has
if you have an odd number of image
layers then i suggest you have one
sprite pro row so it'll just be a long
column of images with no blank spaces it
will also warn you if there will be any
blank spaces depending on how many
sprites per row you chose
and this is great because we do not want
blank spaces in our sprite sheet this
will mean that the animation will have
one blank space as a frame in its
animation so that means that it will
just become invisible for a frame which
is not good step six import your
spreadsheet into unreal engine to import
your new sprite sheet into unreal engine
you simply drag and drop your sprite
sheet image once doing so it will be
imported as a texture to set up my
textures i use these settings i put
lossy compression amount at its lowest
so that it will have the best image
quality even though it is the largest
file so beware of that
and i untick srgb to make sure that the
sprite is transparent once we turn it
into a material step seven create the
animation within a material i personally
use materials to handle my sprite
animations because it allows me more
control over things such as speed and
color when creating my material i will
always create a master material that
will hold adjustable parameters that i
can adjust through material instances
when i create multiples animations
yes
this master material is set up as such
the material domain uses surface
for use on a 3d material if you want to
use the rotoscope animation for ui you
can also change this to user interface i
use a masked blend mode so the material
will be transparent and i also take two
sided to ensure that the material can be
viewed by both sides if this is needed
you might not need this within a
material you can create material
parameters that can be adjusted in real
time without having to recompile the
material this makes it very easy for us
to keep the same master material set up
while making the appropriate adjustments
for each of its material instances when
using a material parameter you can
change its name within its details panel
so that it's easily recognizable for you
when it comes to adjusting that
parameter the flipbook node is what
drives the animation so i use scalar
parameter values for
speed which is a constant parameter that
gets multiplied by the time node
and then gets plugged into the animation
phase input in the flipbook node row
number which gets input into the number
of rows input in the flipbook node and
column number which gets input into the
number of columns input the flipbook
uv's output is then fed into a texture
sample parameter 2d which will be set to
the sprite sheet i often hook the output
of this to a multiply node with a vector
parameter so that i can use this to set
a color that can override the base color
of the sprite texture if needed hence
why i said i draw in white because it's
easy to
override this white color with a
multiply of pink purple green yellow
whatever color you want it to be the rgb
output of your texture sample parameter
2d gets fed into the base color
and i also added mine into the emissive
color
i'm not sure why i did that i don't
think i had to do that did i have to do
that
and use the alpha output for the opacity
mask input of the material to set the
transparency once this is set up you can
create material instances of this master
material to adjust the parameters for
each instance to do this you simply
right click on the master material and
choose create material instance if you
followed my material walkthrough then
the parameter values that you should
have available to you are speed which is
the speed the flip book will run through
the sprite sheet row number which is the
amount of rows the spreadsheet has
column number the amount of columns this
worksheet has texture which is the
sprite sheet to use and color the
adjustable color of the sprite step 8
getting your animation into your 3d
scene to insert this into your 3d scene
you can simply add a plane into your map
by choosing plane from within the place
actors window under shapes
set this plane to use your material
ta-da
it's playing
it even plays in the editor which is
really great because you can see it
without having to run your game that
method works great when you have fixed
camera angles however you might want to
use this method in a first person game
where the player controls the camera and
you want to make sure that they will
always see your animation from front on
to not break the illusion well don't
worry i've thought of this too in this
case you can create a blueprint that
holds your playing component which has
your animation as its material and
within this blueprint you can set the
actor to rotate upon its z-axis to
follow the camera on tick i'd suggest
turning tick on or off when you need it
so that it's more performant but this
was just a super quick blueprint that i
mocked up for you just so that you can
see that this is possible for you so
there you have it a simple yet effective
way of adding animation into your annual
engine project i hope you enjoyed this
tutorial there are many different ways
to create rotoscope animations and to
import sprite animations into your
project for instance unreal engine does
actually have sprite actions but they
don't allow you as much control as the
method i've shared with you today
and i've learned through the comments of
my previous video that you can actually
create vertiscope animation through
using blender and other 3d softwares
which i think is super cool and
definitely worth a look at but i
personally have been really enjoying
this particular process in creating
rotoscope animation and getting it into
the game
i feel it gives me full control over the
visuals of it
the speed things that i want to add that
aren't necessarily in my reference
footage
and i'm always happy with the end result
it really does remind me of the
traditional frame by frame animations
that i have initially been inspired by
so
for me it's a win saying all of that
though if there's a different way that
you incorporate your animations into
unreal engine or if you think that this
process can be improved then please let
me know in the comments down below
i'd love to learn together with you
that's the whole point of why i do these
types of videos and i definitely need to
say thank you thank you thank you so
much for all of the the absolute love
that i got on my how to make a music
video in annual engine
i did not expect it to blow up in such a
way and i think it's absolutely awesome
that there's so many people that want to
use game engines to create things other
than games
for so long i've been a lover of film
and video games and i was just waiting
for them to merge and i feel like now is
the time i know that it's been
used in such a way for a while but yeah
i'm rambling it was just so awesome to
see so many people who
um wanted to share their own projects
wanted to
express how it had inspired them it
makes me very happy so thank you thank
you very much and it meant that the
channel has now grown enough to get a
thank you button so you can say thank
you down here if you want to you don't
have to but i've been waiting for that
button so thank you
the youtube has been very very good to
the channel lately talking of supporting
the channel i want to say a big thank
you to my patreons who make this all
possible thanks to colin williams no way
jose gaming with malachi 79 f-196 lewis
cruz you hang leio luke sugars and
salvatore merrifield and i'm very sorry
if i butchered anyone's names if you
want to catch more of this face then
join me every thursday at 8 30 pm bst
over on twitch
twitch.tv
yagaman to see me play video games i
will sometime it may be doing a game dev
creative project q a over on twitch
which i'll then cut down and pop onto
youtube
i had a lot of questions
asked of me and i would love to help as
many of you as possible but also of
course i don't know everything
i think we can help each other in that
way though we can build a community that
can help each other and just make cool
creative things together that's all i've
ever wanted and i feel like it's coming
true so i'm very happy how about you oh
that rant would be very cool
that didn't rhyme okay have a lovely day
or evening i'll see you in the next
video and bye
doesn't mind my high five